so how much of sort of current life
is in your in your new show and act your
age well
was this something you'd been working on
sort of pre i already had my i've been
working on my act and you know i may
mention a little bit about my wife and
my situation but uh it's not really
about that you know this is the last set
the deported world here was more
introspective and right about that but
this time it's more from
the perspective of what's going on in
this world right now right and and what
is going on in this world right now
right what are you covering
well you know i'm covering cancer
culture i'm covering the
uh the millennials and the gen z's yeah
and uh and as opposed to pointing the
finger at them i'm actually pointing the
finger at our generation
what what did we do we created those
generations no we did we are mad at what
we created we didn't create you feel
that you you're taking responsibility
for we are you know why we took away all
adversity from them
we were the ones that said who our
generation was one said you know what
everything i didn't like about my
childhood i'm not gonna put my kids
through and that's where we screwed up
because that
all that adversity made us stronger
more uh interesting people right the
more struggle you have the more you have
to pull from the more you get to look at
you know right we our generation sold
crack in the 80s yes uh well these are
the kids
of those crowds these are crackpots
are you disappointed or fascinated by
canceled culture or does it fit back and
forth i uh i'm neither yeah
i've actually never met
one human being that is into that world
right
i know it exists online read it you read
it i know it exists online but how do we
know those aren't russian bots we don't
we don't have you met somebody else i'm
outraged um no i've heard from people
who are outraged yeah but you hear from
them online
yeah but some stuff they say
i mean no i mean listen you put your
phone down it doesn't it like it doesn't
exist like i can i'm fine because of the
generation we are i can turn it off
because i remember what life was like
without that right i'm fine i'm i'm good
i'm good but no but i i think that it's
i think it's interesting because it's
something that so many people want to
talk about but like you said does it
exist outside of that
yeah i don't know that it does
and people like oh are you gonna change
your act because i go why would i change
my act yeah i'm a steakhouse people are
coming to me to get steak just because
everybody else is going vegan doesn't
mean i'm going to start serving bean
burgers at my steakhouse
what else is on the menu what else is
fascinating you right now in this show
uh i don't know that kind of stuff and
uh
uh you know i i really go into like the
history of it all you do yeah i did a
lot of research and and what did you
find in all the research
i found there's a lot of paths that got
us to where we're at right
and i could only focus on one so
yeah i focused uh at the end of my act i
focus on the history of porn right
because
it's it started here and now it's
extreme i mean it was always considered
extreme but now it's extreme now it's
actually and it matches the times that
we're living in right which is extreme
times right and how does that go over
with um an entire audience oh they dig
it yeah they dig it because they're
already coming to see me they're coming
to see what i do
um and uh you know it's it's fun for me
because a lot of people are like oh he
sounds like the old russell again yeah
and i'm like this is great but does that
hurt a little bit when somebody says
that you sound like the old russell
again no no because i think they're
referring to the happiness i used to
i used to have a happiness about me
right
yeah it's you know it's like not
i'm not as affected anymore right but
people and as long as you get older you
start to care less very much so and i
care much less yes i don't care about
the industry
i don't care about an award show yeah i
don't care about a red carpet i get
invited to them all the time and i'm
like
i'm just gonna stay in i'm good but do
you not find that people still hang on
to the old sort of trope that comics are
miserable anyway i mean i'm sure people
try to but
you can't be successful and miserable at
the same time
yeah like you're you're being you're
doing it to yourself at that point yeah
but do you not find that sometimes great
jokes or great art comes out of being in
those places and then maybe people
gravitate towards those places a little
too frequently oh yeah no i think a lot
of times comics sabotage their own life
they do just to get into that place
right and i knew that that's what i was
doing before you were
and uh i
i found it to be
not
useful no
and i and i kind of revel in joy more
yeah so i'm gonna stick with the joy
and you're you're in canada are you
doing 20 shows in canada uh something
like that yeah that's a lot of shows in
canada
it's a lot of places we've got a big
country and how long did you work this
show before taking it on the road
i had started it
it's been worked on for about two years
now the most yeah yeah
almost two years now i i it's gone
through some changes and it's tightened
up and it's
it flows did you do small clubs oh yeah
getting up to this you have to yeah
that's right right does some stuff play
better in small clubs than it would on a
big stage um i've
some of it yeah sure yeah
do you know
you don't really know which one
i mean there's moments where you're
going to get half the crowd moaning and
the other half laughing right and then
you know it you're not sure when you're
in the big arena where how much of
that's gonna be loud moan and how much
you're gonna be allowed laughter right
uh everybody's talking about you know
comics now with chappelle getting run up
on stage and chris rock at the oscars is
that a thing are you guys talking about
that no i don't listen i've been doing
jiu jitsu for seven years yeah i i've
you know i've it's come at your own risk
really right especially the way that guy
came at chapel like he came with his
neck out yes
bam good night that's mine have you ever
but has this ever even been a topic of
conversation because to me it seems like
crossing that line
is just something that was never done at
a comedy show i was always right it was
always a danger always was it really
it's always been a danger and it's
happened over throughout the years you
know it's just never happened to bigger
name comics right you know it may have
happened to dave and chris back in the
day too you know there was always those
moments in my career where there's
moments where i was like it could go
left here
right but it didn't you know because at
comedy shows you don't see the same sort
of
security presence that you do say at a
concert right or something else you guys
really you get the sense that you are
alone up there we are it's a vulnerable
place to be yeah but if you're high up
on a stage i mean you know you're fine
i'm fine and i'm very aware of my
surroundings and i'm like
i see somebody get up and i've had
people get up and walk towards the stage
yeah but those are just
really excited people to be there and
like literally i'm doing my act and some
some guy walks up to the front of stage
with a picture and a pen he's like can
you sign this i'm like do you not see me
doing my act right now right and then
security comes at him i'm like he's not
bothering me he's just
he's just untimely
we haven't seen in
you know
press the analyzing of comics materials
like this since i was trying to think
the last time
that amount of attention was paid to a
comic's material and like i'm thinking
maybe going back like andrew dice clay
era kind of thing of where it broke out
of that world and became news now
everybody's act is news
yeah i mean you know they want to
it's i always say the industry is
cannibalizing itself right now
i mean they're trying to implement this
rule and that rule and you need to worry
about that feeling and those feelings
and i'm like no
no we're everybody's so self-centered
and so into how they feel
that
they feel you need to feel it too and
i'm like no
that's not the way the world works right
and you can't talk about inclusion and
exclude people
that's not what inclusion is you like
include us be inclusive i'm like you're
included yeah but but what about those
guys no we got to cut them out because
they're not they're not well that's not
what inclusion is right inclusion has to
be everybody whether you like what
they're saying or don't like what
they're saying or if you like what they
stand for you don't like what they stand
for it's not in your business if you
don't like it right if you don't like it
and don't support it that's your problem
right but you can't exclude somebody for
that
um unless it's hateful
then i get it if it's hateful because i
got that though but who decides that
well you it's hateful is you know when
it's hateful sure you know when it's
hateful and then you know when you're
being picky and making it look like it's
hateful but people say something is
hateful that you may not feel as hateful
and they truly believe that it is
listen i i i here's something
controversial when they came at joe
rogan and said that he was racist yeah i
made a post on my page to let people
know that joe was my friend yeah and
i've known him for 12 years and i know
for a fact that that man is not racist
on any day on any level right and my
friends my black comic friends came at
me d.l hughley called me yeah i was like
yo i just want to tell you something
russ i don't care i know and i'm like
daryl i'm telling you this man is not a
racist yeah he's there's not a racist
bone in the guy's body i would defend
him to the end of the earth right and
the same thing when they came at
roseanne i know roseanne i know who
these people are yeah just because you
say something doesn't mean it's going to
it needs to stick it's not fair right
you know and listen i'm not to blow up
joe rogan's spot but his daughter's
black he's never once mentioned it no in
all the defenses he could have made
sure yeah you know he raised a black
girl who loves him very much and calls
him dad i mean like it's not you can't
be a racist and do that right fair
enough when you come back to canada do
you have a ton of family up here no of
course everybody's here so what's that
like when you come back can you are you
listen i gotta plan it out over days
who's who i'm gonna see this day i'm
gonna see that day is there an order
like do people get pissed if you don't
see in the specific order of who gets
first i you know it's one of those
things where i most of them understand
now you know because i'm usually in and
out for a day but i flew in last night
from puerto rico right i'm here today
and i'm out tomorrow evening right you
know what i mean so it's not like i'm
here for this extended amounts of time i
don't even have a house anymore you know
huh so i can't even hear that i feel
weird you don't have a house in canada
anymore it sucks not having a house here
yeah would you do it again buy a house
yeah hell yeah yeah not necessarily
that's well not now yeah but i you know
i sold my house to mitch marner you did
yeah no and then a couple weeks ago he
gave me a black range rover
i was
i was hanging out on the queen's way
with a couple of my friends and um
too soon